las conocidas como terapias de
corrección de la orientación sexual han
sido prohibidas en ciudad de méxico a
pesar que desde 2012 la ope s ha
advertido que estos pseudo tratamientos
carecen de justificación médica siguen
siendo muy habituales en américa latina
asia o áfrica lo que es considerado como
un ataque a los derechos de la comunidad
lgtb y será penado entre 2 y 5 años de
prisión para aquellos que lo ejerzan u
obligan a practicarlo hay una serie de
personas e instituciones que se
organizan para reprimir a las personas
sobre todo que tiene una característica
no hegemónica no normativa como lo es la
orientación sexual la identidad de
género no en la mayoría de las ocasiones
son los propios familiares quienes
inducen o obligan a la víctima a acudir
a estas terapias lugares en los que se
han reportado rituales religiosos abusos
físicos violaciones y tratamientos
pseudo médicos mi papá intentó hacer
varios esfuerzos por corregir más bien
hizo varios esfuerzos por corregir mi
orientación sexual desde llevarme a
múltiples psicólogos para que me dijeran
que la decisión porque no es una edición
que está tomando estaba mal
desde llevarme a cuba por trabajadoras
sexuales hasta quitarme el derecho a
estudiar espero estas organizaciones que
promocionan la corrección sexual siguen
presentes en el resto de méxico en
guadalajara pseudo terapistas como
everardo martínez siguen presumiendo de
que sus tratamientos funcionan y
defienden que a sus sesiones acuden
personas con sentimientos que no
eligieron y que buscan corregir